the trump campaign has spent a lot of
time attacking joe biden
for things that don't make any sense so
they'll attack joe biden for being too
tough
on crime that was actually a line of
attack for a while or they'll attack joe
biden for
formerly supporting the traditional
definition of marriage
so that's like a terrible thing and it
just didn't make sense it didn't have a
great connection
i think to the base finally well i don't
know what's going on in the campaign
but they seem to have hit the right
direction again
they are finally attacking joe biden and
the democrats broadly
for something that makes sense they're
making the point and this will be
a central if not the central theme of
the campaign
democrats are dangerous
seattle's pledged to defund its police
department
by 50 even including a proposal to
remove
9-1-1 dispatchers from police control
you can see this kind of guy trying to
break into the background
old a woman of a certain age
trying to call the police i'm sorry that
there is no one here to answer your
emergency call
but leave a message and we'll get back
to you as soon as we can
rise significantly donald j trump and i
approve this message
you won't be safe in joe biden's america
that's the key that's the message that's
the sort of thing people care about not
these silly ancillary issues
the central message how to protect your
life
how to protect your livelihood the trump
campaign the right broadly
has lost the narrative over the past few
months
and which it didn't make a lot of sense
because the right has always been so
good at seeing
the problems with the left's message
messaging particularly very well
on the internet where there's no
gatekeepers well finally the right is
taking back
the memes of production i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show you know i
asked everybody yesterday a sports open
backup if your favorite sports team
takes a knee how will you respond and my
favorite comment on this
came from i suspect someone who's been
around for a little while
i've been a new york san francisco
giants fan
since 1954. many of them took a knee at
their first exhibition game last monday
i am done with them and with baseball
well said i you know some people have
asked me
why uh why i would go after my new york
yankees
because they knelt before the the
national anthem they didn't kneel during
the national anthem so it's totally cool
right
wrong we'll get into that a little bit
later also i got to thank our friends
over at wise foods
as you probably know our sponsor company
wise company
has changed their name to ready wise
different name same great product
now is a better time than ever in my
lifetime i think to be prepared with
long-term nutritional food options
ready wise has a lot of options like
emergency meals freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables
for convenient on-the-go nutrition new
adventure meals for hiking camping and
other outdoor activities
not a lot of things to do these days
other than go hiking and camping so you
can check that out too
get peace of mind during these uncertain
times knowing that your family is
prepared
with plenty of reliable nutritional
meals that have a very
very long shelf life they use the finest
ingredients and latest food prep
technology to ensure optimal taste and
freshness
meals are packed into durable long
lasting pouches
designed to keep food fresh for up to 25
years that's pretty good to know
especially as things are so uncertain
these days
i really like these guys a lot i trust
them this week my listeners can get free
shipping
at readywise.com when entering knowles k
wlas at checkout or by calling
855-453-2945
readywise has a 90-day no questions
asked return policy no risk
in taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today it is
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e-com promo code knowles
to get free shipping
we're finally taking back the memes of
production
actually the person who kind of even put
this thought into my head yesterday
was not some rock ribbed right winger
the person who put this into my head
was elon musk elon musk the space man
the tesla man he tweeted out he's been
tweeting out more provocative things in
recent days
things that contradict the leftist
narrative so he tweeted out this image
of karl marx
and it was like one of these quote meme
images it was karl marx on one side and
then it said
give me dot for free hungry santa
because coral marx looks kind of like
hungry santa
and it's a dust capital in a nutshell he
summed up
marx's most famous book if you've ever
tried to read it it's hard to call it
his greatest work
because it's absolutely unreadable but
it's considered it's considered his
his greatest work and then elon tweeted
out after this kind of joke he tweeted
out
something that i think republicans and
conservatives should pay attention to
he tweeted out quote the left is
losing the middle and i think for a lot
of us
whose head is in politics all the time
you know we're constantly reading what's
going on on the internet and on twitter
and
and even cable news or something like
that it's
it's easy to forget that a lot of people
don't spend
all of their time thinking about
politics a lot of people do other things
right they have lives
outside of politics and so there
this is why the left is so effective
because the left controls all of the
institutions
in particular the media institutions so
if you're only spending i don't know
20 minutes a day hearing anything about
politics you're only going to hear the
left
left's message you probably haven't
heard the rights message but the left is
going
so far in a radical direction
that even people who are in the middle
who maybe
are not paying a ton of attention who
don't have particularly strong
ideological views one way or the other
they're beginning to notice huh even
though i haven't been reading politico
all day i know i don't want to be with
the people tearing down george
washington statues
even though i don't know i'm not totally
paying attention i don't want to be with
the people
burning down american cities or
attacking
different americans or burning down
federal courthouses
right there the left is in fact losing
the middle
why are they losing the middle no i
think what the trump campaign and other
republicans have tried to do up until
this point in the campaign
is basically pander on left-wing issues
so they've gone after joe biden for
being too tough on crime in 1994
because they think that's going to help
them win the black vote which to me it's
such
obvious transparent pandering it's
that's not the right strategy or they'll
go after joe biden because they'll say
he wasn't
pro gay marriage early enough or
something like that
you just think that's going to win over
the middle the middle doesn't care about
that the middle
who doesn't have a lot of time to pay
attention to politics just cares about
basic things keep my family safe
support my country be able to go to work
right simple things where the
republicans could be winning
if they would just take the message
there and i think finally that's what's
beginning
to happen with the trump campaign and
with others the radicalism is not just
at the national level it's in every one
of these democrat cities you know
chicago mayor laurie lightfoot obviously
is running one of the worst managed
cities in all of america
they have huge problems there in
particular crime i mean parts of chicago
it's like you're walking around downtown
fallujah
sometimes and so in the midst of all
this president trump comes in and says
look if you can't take care of your city
i'm going to send in the federal
government
to instill order because we're not going
to permit
an american city to be a war zone and
lori lightfoot mayor of chicago goes on
cnn doesn't say thank you federal
government
please help us doesn't admit that she's
got a problem in her city
she goes on and she says she doesn't
want the problem
to get fixed we can't just allow
anyone to come into chicago play police
in our streets in our neighborhoods when
they don't know the first thing
about our city that's a recipe for
disaster and that's what you're seeing
playing out in portland on a nightly
basis we don't need that here
that is not a value-add and it doesn't
help enhance our public safety
you do need that it would be a value add
it would help enhance your public safety
first of all this idea that the federal
agents are playing cop
no i think they're they've got a much
more successful record
at law enforcement than lori lightfoot
does in chicago and by the way
the head of the police union in chicago
says that everything she just said is bs
and actually the head of the police
union in chicago is asking for the
federal help
because the civil authority there people
like lori lightfoot
and other democrats that run other
democratic cities
are not enforcing the law enough
forget chicago look over at new york
city new york right now
shootings are up they had 47 shootings
last week not last month not the last
two months
not the last six months 47 shootings
last week do you know what what spike
that is that's a 176 percent
spike compared to the same period
last year that's according to police
sources in new york
who are these people that got killed
well one of them 16 year old
shot in the head and killed 16 year old
kid teenager
another one 18 year old shot in the head
actually survived
unbelievably wonderfully in critical
condition though
because of the mayhem on the streets of
new york and what is that mayhem caused
well it's caused by
not enforcing the law undercutting the
police
stoking a narrative that the police are
racist slaughtering innocent black men
across the country which is a lie
encouraging people to go out and riot
locking people up not letting them go to
work
for six months at a time how long has it
been now it's been
what four or five months at this point
and
and the argument for all of this do you
remember the argument for all of this
from andrew cuomo the governor of new
york who was handed
handled this lockdown slash plague slash
riot crisis worse than any governor in
america do you know what his argument
was
for his draconian restrictions his
argument was
if it saves one life if it saves just
one
life this is about saving lives
and if everything we do saves just
one life i'll be happy
what if everything you do leads to 176
spike in shootings then then it will not
have been worth it i assume who's going
to be held responsible for that
forget even i mean moving past the
shootings aspect of this
andrew cuomo's specific coveted policies
killed thousands of senior citizens
didn't save lives who's held responsible
for that
the middle the people who don't have a
whole lot of time
who they only hear snippets from the
mainstream media
that's what they want to hear about they
want to simple things
lives don't get too abstract you don't
need to get into
you know lofty gender theory to win them
over
say that you're going to protect people
meanwhile what are democrats doing
they're undercutting their argument even
more now they're talking
about defunding military recruitment we
will turn
to our favorite socialist from queens
really from westchester county but she
says she's from
queens and the bronx but first i got to
thank our friends over at zip recruiter
zip recruiter makes hiring
so easy hire you know hiring can be very
very
difficult and uh part of the reason for
this
is you know a lot of old hiring boards
just it's basically
throwing spaghetti at the wall you don't
know how you're gonna find somebody zip
recruiters smart matching technology
finds people with the right experience
for your job in fact four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day
that is how housing liar found alexandra
roja alexandra never imagined she could
get a reporter job in the midst of
covid19 when hiring is frozen
and the idea of looking for a job was
discouraging so she created a profile on
zip recruiters if recruiter matched
alexandra into housingwire's reporter
job
because her degree and writing skills
were a great fit
for the role housing wire received her
application only four hours
after they posted the job a few weeks
later alexandra starts her dream
career zip recruiter helped alexandra
find the right job they helped housing
wire find the right person
for their role fast and they can help
you see how zip recruiter
can help you hire try it for free
right now at zip recruiter dot com slash
knowles canada w l e
s that's ziprecruiter.com knowles
people dropping like flies around here
bullets flying all over our streets not
just in
chicago but also in new york also in
portland all over the place
right people are concerned about their
safety people are concerned about
even outside of america are adversaries
aggressing on us
china seems to be doing that and what
does aoc say she wants to do
she wants to defund military recruitment
she's hiding this in a defense spending
bill this is an amendment
to a defense spending bill she wants to
defund
recruiting in schools you know when
you're in high school and the military
recruiter comes in
it's like a rite of passage if you
happen to go to public school in america
she wants to get rid of that completely
she wants to borrow the military
from advertising or interacting with
people on twitch or any video game
esports or live streaming platform
and this is the statement she had she
made about it she put this out to defend
her indefensible egregious decision
whether through recruitment stations in
their lunchrooms or now through esports
teams children in low-income communities
are persistently targeted for enlistment
the military can for some provide a
rewarding career
but low-income americans are not being
given anywhere near the same information
or access to trade schools
college or other postgraduate
opportunities
now listen she's saying they're not
being given enough
information and that's why we need to
take away the information that we're
giving them about the military
the kids in these communities don't have
good opportunities so we need to take
away
one of the opportunities that they have
doesn't make a lot of sense
i mean even the language he uses the
military can for some
provide a rewarding career that's
outrageous
it's a it's an extraordinarily rewarding
career and it's a career for which
we are all grateful we civilians are all
very grateful because the military keeps
us safe
you know this was the one the one it
used to be in america the one aspect
of american politics that was beyond
partisan infighting was the military you
know the democrats would want to defund
the military itself
pull back defense spending the
republicans would want to beef it up a
little bit more
but that's a little different than
what's happening here what aoc is saying
here is
we actually need to stop people from
joining the military
we need to minimize recruitment
because it's bad for people and the
military preys on low-income people
not the case by the way a lot of my
family a lot of my family
has served in the military and the the
picture that that is painted by
left-wing democrats is simply
not the case this is a great thing to
run on
you know the president trump has has
made this habit of campaigning on the
american flag in the fourth of july
and would you believe it the democrats
took the bait and now they oppose the
american flag and the fourth of july
and our founding fathers and apparently
now even joining the military
great thing great thing to run on great
great meme
great thing to put out there aoc not
just the military she wants to
defund recruitment for she also wants to
defund the police
and this brings us back to the chaos
happening on our streets
because there's a political question
here which is who does this help
you know some people seem to think that
trump is allowing the cities to burn
down
because it helps him politically these
are democrat cities that shows the
effects of democrat policies
that's what the oakland mayor believes
the oakland mayor libby schaaf
told oakland residents she thinks that
the vandalism
helps trump she said vandalizing our
downtown gives donald trump the images
he wants
and the justification he seeks to send
federal troops into american cities
do you think donald trump wants to send
federal troops into american cities
of course not of are you insane
what what does he gain from sending the
federal troops in first of all if he did
gain don't you think he would have done
it
now months ago when all of this rioting
began
it's been going on for two months
wouldn't he have started it a little
sooner if it helped him
it doesn't help him at all because all
you need is one federal agent
discharging one round from their gun and
it's game over you're gonna hear this is
kent state all over again
this is a fascist attack on the people
rising up and minorities and
blah blah blah whatever nonsense the
left is spouting
this is a terrible thing for president
trump now there is a little bit of a
political advantage
to people being able to see a difference
they say gosh i don't want my city
to look like that like this democrat run
city but i'm not sure
people even put two and two together on
which party is managing those cities
in fact the images only really help
trump
if trump can fix the problem
the images help trump if trump can
effectively go in and and
fix the mess that the democrats have
made if if donald trump can't do that if
if donald trump just points over there
and says look at how all those cities
are burning
re-elect me to save america that's not a
compelling argument because people are
going to look at him and say why do i
need to re-elect you you're the
president now
fix the problem now this is donald
trump's whole argument
the whole reason that people elected him
is because he went and he said i'm not a
regular politician
i don't know all the stupid stuff that
they always say i'm not all talk no
action
i build things i do things i'm not build
this country back up and do things here
that's that's what we like about the guy
he cuts through the bs
well if he can't get that done then
actually these scenes are going to hurt
him they've put him in a terrible
position
i have a great deal of sympathy for him
here but that's the key
the democrats are betting on president
trump not being able to fix this problem
and president trump now looks like he's
fixing it
the the dhs or the doj rather has just
announced the arrests that they've made
around the country they've arrested 236
people around the country
and 238 defendants have been charged
nationwide in quote cases related
to violent opportunists and civil unrest
this according to the doj spokesman 24
74 rather
people in portland have been arrested 60
of whom were charged with federal crimes
for alleged acts that they committed
against federal police or facilities
huzzah this is good this is good because
you look at these videos going around
the country
and you think all you want is for these
people to be arrested
all you want is for these guys to face
some consequences and finally
this is pretty good at the federal level
to be able to charge 230 some odd people
this is good i call it a start because
really you'd like to charge the 300 400
500 however many of these people are
coming out
and attacking people's businesses
federal property people's people's
livelihoods lives
people are dying in the streets right
that's what you want that's the message
run on law and order run on fixing
things
run on keeping people safe all the other
nonsense
all the the other washington consultant
bs where you're going to be able to seem
like you're running to the left of joe
biden on transgender rights or something
that's not it man that's not
what is going to move people to the
polls
of of any political view frankly in
november
the stakes are too high here it's not
just that we feel
like our our safety is threatened from
these roving marauding gangs of vandals
we also think that our safety is
threatened by this china virus
that has taken over the world and
frankly people think our livelihoods
might be threatened by politicized
science because there are treatments for
the china virus
that are now being suppressed it seems
for political reasons and on this exact
point
there's a group of doctors that showed
up yesterday to the supreme court
in washington uh this was led by the dr
stella emmanuel
and she said that hydroxychloroquine
remember hydroxyclaric when it was a
treatment for coronavirus early on
is being suppressed for political
reasons because president trump
is the orange man and the orange man is
bad and so you had
you saw a lot of evidence that
hydroxychloroquine particularly combined
with a few other things was
working very well to treat coronavirus
early on then you saw
some science papers published medical
papers
saying that hydroxychloroquine was
actually killing people it was so
terrible
and then everyone stopped doing it
because trump touted it then
you found out that those papers were
retracted because they were trash
they were just politicized and now this
woman comes out and says
cut it out with the politics help cure
people
put the medicine first i've taken care
of over 350 patients who've not lost one
not a diabetic not as somebody with high
blood pressure not somebody with asthma
not an old person who's not lost one
patient and
on top of that i put myself my staff and
many doctors that i know
on hydroxyl gloping for prevention
because by the very mechanism of
action he works early and as a
prophylaxis we see patients
10 to 15 profit patients every day we
give them breathing treatments we only
wear surgical masks none of us have
gotten sick
it works i'm upset why i'm upset is that
i see people that cannot breathe
i see parents walk in i see diabetics
sit in my office
knowing that this is a death sentence
and they can't breathe
and i hug them and i tell them it's
gonna be okay you're gonna live
and we treat them and they live none has
died
so if some fake science some person
sponsored by all these fake pharma
companies comes out say oh
we've done studies and they found out
that it doesn't work i can tell you
categorically it's fake science
how do you think the left responded to
this woman and the whole group of people
wearing white lab coats standing behind
her
they said i kid you not they said
that this was politicized science
politicized science what do you think
you people have been doing
for the past three months four months
five months however long it's been going
on
it's unbelievable they the the left says
science is not political follow the
science follow the white lab coat listen
to our white lab coats
even though they told you to do one
thing and then they told you to do the
opposite of that thing the next day
don't just listen to them whatever they
say and so then all of a sudden
we point to some white lab coats and we
say well what about those people those
people are saying something else they
say no that's political
so only the leftist scientists those are
the only good ones but
apparently the i don't even know what
this woman's politics are but let's just
say she's conservative
the conservative scientists you're not
allowed to listen to so they try to
discredit her
they do all the things that they accuse
the right of having done for the past
few months
and they try to discredit this woman in
particular but
unfortunately there is a bit of a
scientific consensus behind what she's
saying
including by very fancy people with very
fancy titles who go to all the fancy
schools that the left loves
namely just recently just last week
a doctor and professor harvey a rich
md phd professor of epidemiology at the
yale school
of public health this guy is the author
of 300 over 300 peer-reviewed
publications
he holds senior positions on the
editorial boards of several leading
journals this guy checks every single
box of leftist expert scientists well he
wrote
in an op-ed in newsweek last week that
the key to defeating coronavirus already
exists
we need to start using it it's called
hydroxychloroquine
so he backs up exactly exactly what this
woman is saying
the left ignores it the left doesn't
want to hear about it because trump
touted hydroxychloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine is simple and it
might help and it might reopen the
country
and the left doesn't want to reopen the
country not yet
they don't want to they want to reopen
the country maybe on november 4th
day after the election day it's the only
explanation there is
nothing that the lockdowns could
possibly do
at this point for public health not a
thing
the point of the lockdowns was to
flatten the curve so that we didn't
overwhelm the hospital system
even at the peak of this we never came
anywhere close there's no sign that we
will
then flatten the curve became fine to
cure well we do have certain treatments
that seem to work very well
but what about the vaccine even dr fauci
even the exalted dr fauci tells us the
vaccine
will be at best what 70 percent
effective and
a lot of people won't get the vaccine
anyway so we won't get hurt immunity so
we won't even be able to get the herd
immunity if we were to lock down
and wait for the vaccine there is
nothing left to do
other than keep shooting ourselves in
the foot and stay closed and destroy the
economy and destroy
the schooling system which frankly that
part of it might be the silver lining
and storm cloud
and wait until november and hope that we
can
get joe biden through the election
that's that's the argument
entirely political or we could listen to
some of those doctors
all of a sudden i'm i'm interested in
listening to some doctors
but the left the left won't let us do it
don't forget public health experts are
part
politician and they're part scientists
that's why public health right public
health
is having to do with politics
we can't ignore that there's a political
dimension of this but we can try to
follow the science i'll show you a
little bit of science that i just ran
into yesterday
i finally i was going to break down and
buy a mask because some for some places
they won't let you inside if you don't
have a mask on and i like to pick up my
sushi sometimes so i need a mask
so i'm looking around and say okay fine
i'll buy this stupid mask i'll get one
of them i can pull it out and wear it
when i go inside or something
so i'm looking at the products you can
get these masks on amazon you can get
them
at old navy you can get them at a time
basically every clothing store now makes
the masks you can get them
all over the internet then i see on
every single one of them
a disclaimer this mask is not intended
for medical use and not proven to reduce
the transmission of disease
this mask is not fda approved not
intended for medical use and not proven
to reduce the transmission of disease
this product makes no claim of
antimicrobial protection antiviral
protection particulate filtration or
infection prevention or reduction
please note that these masks are not
intended as a replacement for medical
grade ppe
and do not cure or prevent any diseases
that's a funny disclaimer to have on all
of the masks which we are told now the
science has changed and the masks
protect us
uh it doesn't sound like it from the
disclaimers now you might say well
michael it's because
the the government agencies just don't
move fast enough
to change the disclaimer the government
agency is the agency telling us to wear
the stupid masks
so you'd think if they could move fast
enough to issue this guidance
they could move fast enough to remove
the disclaimer but they don't remove the
disclaimer because the science hasn't
changed
because as we i read it on the show a
few days ago on the cdc website put up
as recently as may
there are 14 clinical studies showing
that the masks
don't do bupkus very very little do the
masks do
and yet and yet people are being
told to buy all of them and they're
being told to buy all of them
because it's a political symbol now
let's say though let's say that you
are more inclined to trust the experts
which fine i totally understand
uh better safe than sorry i don't think
that's the i don't think it's actually
safer
and and i and i i do think the risk is
pretty great but let's say okay whatever
that's fine it's just a mask who cares
what reason do i have to trust the
public health experts look the cases are
surging right aren't the cases surging
maybe they are maybe they're surging
maybe they're not
because 600 000 people in just
the last few weeks were just
misdiagnosed with covet actually i'm
sorry those six hundred thousand people
were misdiagnosed
in one day we'll get to that in just one
second we will get to
major league baseball and why i'm giving
up on my yankees after a lifetime of
being a yankee fan
we will get to a whole lot of stuff but
first i've got to thank you
we've got to thank you for heading on
over and subscribing to the michael
knowles show youtube channel not just
the daily wire youtube channel
yeah it's good to give ben the views and
the subscriptions
but frankly even better in my opinion
head over to the michael show youtube
channel
thank you for ringing that bell
subscribing also if you're not already a
daily wire member
you should consider getting a reader's
pass one buck for your first month
three bucks a month after that you get
access to exclusive editorials
at you get articles ad free you get
access to our mobile app
you get stuff by like the one and only
matt walsh says i looked up every case
of an unarmed black man shot by cops in
2019
here's the truth the left is hiding go
through every single one of those
cases and a lot of other great stuff too
sign up for just a buck
head on over to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
six hundred thousand people misdiagnosed
with coronavirus
in the blink of an eye not even over the
course of weeks just very quickly
tricare is the healthcare program of the
us department of defense
military health system they mistakenly
told 600 000 people that they have the
china virus
and they asked these covid survivors to
consider donating blood for research
600 000 in the military with coronavirus
that doesn't make a lot of sense
because the last number i saw is that 31
000 people
affiliated with the us military so we're
not even just talking about servicemen
people even affiliated with the military
have actually been diagnosed with the
coronavirus and this is
uh an order of magnitude and double
that so that's not good but you might
say okay michael look
that's just like some health care agency
sent out a full a bad email but
these things happen people get mistaken
emails well what about in florida
because we're getting a lot of false
positives two weeks ago florida state
health department
confirmed that some testing laboratories
in the state have not been disclosing
their negative test results so this is
skewing
the positivity rate dramatically and
this is this is skewing it way
way up and at least two labs were
discovered to have inflated their
positivity rates
by a factor of 10. then we got the story
out of texas through
3 300 people removed from the confirmed
cases roles
i've been getting just anecdotally a
number of
people telling me i i showed up to get a
test
and then the test was never done because
it was going to take two hours to wait
and so i left
i got a call that i was positive that
happened to a friend of mine in los
angeles
same thing with listeners to this show
have written in
said this sort of thing has been
happening to them
i am not a proponent of conspiracy
theories
i am simply pointing out though if you
are not skeptical
of what is coming from the public health
establishment right now
then you're not paying any attention if
you are not skeptical
of what you're hearing from the public
health oh
thank you public health experts
establishment
then i've got a bridge in brooklyn to
sell you you know people
as a result of this are stuck inside and
they're losing their minds and one thing
they're doing
as they're stuck inside is they're
playing video games that's one thing
that people do to pass the time
and joe rogan the king of all podcasting
a very sharp guy joe rogan
doesn't like the video games he says the
video games are a waste of time
joe rogan is completely
wrong about this i cannot believe it
that i
have got to defend video games but i do
take a listen to joe's point
and video games are a real problem their
real problem you know why because
they're [ __ ] fun
and you don't yeah well i'm i have a
real problem with them
and you you you do them and they're real
exciting but you don't get anywhere
right it's like you could do like like
martial arts right you could learn jiu
jitsu
you get obsessed by jiu jitsu and then
three years later
you're you're like an elite jiu jitsu
athlete you're like you're entering in
competitions you're a purple belt
you're moving up yeah you're doing well
you're thinking like i might be able to
open my own school one day that
confidence yeah if i have a hundred
students and those hundred students are
paying me x amount of dollars per month
i can make a living
holy [ __ ] i can have a this would be
amazing and then you see your jiu jitsu
school and your jiu jitsu instructor has
all these students and drives a mercedes
and he's got a nice family and like
that's the future this way you're doing
something exciting and fun and you don't
or you could just be playing video games
three years later you could be that same
kid
just playing video games waiting for the
next vics whatever the
game is you know next xbox game to come
out
and you're gonna waste your time so on
the one level
joe is making an important point which
is don't waste your time doing fruitless
things
but the way he's making the point is
totally wrong
and it's and i think a lot of people
kind of follow
joe's line of argument here but you
shouldn't because that's one of the one
of the problems that's ailing our
society
joe's point is that anything that cannot
possibly make you money is a waste of
your time
even the way he talks about jiu jitsu he
says yeah look jiu jitsu is great you
work on
and jiu jitsu is really great because
then you can start a jiu jitsu school
and make a lot of money from the
students at the jujitsu school
that is for i mean i guess you could in
jiu jitsu but on joe's point that
anything
that can't make you money is a waste of
time not only is that not
true but for the entire history of
western civilization
that has been considered the opposite of
true
actually for the entirety of western
civilization
the things that make you money are
considered relatively
a waste of time compared to the higher
things
what do i mean by that going back all
the way to ancient greece
the thing that man was built for was
for leisure in a certain sense so that
he could contemplate philosophy so that
he could contemplate the good
so that he could focus his mind not just
on the things of this world
but on the things of the higher world
and then in christianity of course this
becomes extraordinarily clear
which is that your point in christianity
is not just to serve
mammon and make a lot of money and build
a lot of big buildings and that's it
for its own sake all of those things can
be fine to do
as long as they are ordered toward the
higher things your ultimate goal
is your salvation your ultimate goal is
to contemplate
god to have the baitific vision to to
work on the things of the spirit
that is what you've got to do
now we've changed this into like i'm
just on my hustle i'm just on my grind
you know i'm just figuring out ways to
make money
you won't you won't be a rounded person
that way you won't have a culture what
is the word culture the word culture
comes from the same root as the word
cult it comes from the word like to
cultivate
you've got to cultivate the human person
and in order to do that you have to
orient it
toward things that you you want to be
cultivated like
so for instance if a what a society
worships will define that society
if a culture worships money it's going
to become a materialistic culture
we're seeing a lot of that today if a
culture worships sex it's going to
become a licentious culture
if a culture worships god if a culture
worships the good
it's going to be a better more godly
culture
and that's that's how you've got to
orient yourself
if if you want to have this good culture
you know conservatives used to
they make this mistake a lot the left
they're all kind of materialists in a
certain in a certain way going back at
least to karl marx
but the wright used to care about these
things and then sometime i don't know
sometime in the 80s
the right decided to trade all that in
for like parodies
of the wolf of wall street or greed is
good or something like that
pretend that all our lives are just
about making money that's not a
conservative point of view
and that's not going to give you a
culture if you say okay yeah we're going
to have
just constant churning of every
traditional institution
and just make more money money money
money money then what are you conserving
you're not you're not a conservative at
all
the other reason beyond all of that
those are kind of the highfalutin
reasons the other reason why
why joe's point i i think is a little
misguided here
is people need a break people need to
relax sometimes i'm not saying you don't
want to be a loaf you don't want to be
slothful
but sometimes people need a break they
need to relax
sometimes video games can provide that
they're like a puzzle right it's like
doing a crossword puzzle or a jigsaw
puzzle or something like that
you don't want it to take over your life
and i think that's the point joe's
actually making
but as a it's a little bit of a break i
think they can be perfectly fine
and more importantly if your life is
only oriented toward making money and
filling up your bank account and that's
all
just for its own sake for no other
reason
that life is no better than the life
squandered playing video games all day
there is there is another option and
that other option is the thing that
for the entire history of our
civilization has been deemed to be
fulfilling and gratifying and it's the
thing that in our now
culture smashing society we seem to have
forgotten
another great diversion it's one that we
all look forward to when spring comes
around
major league baseball i love baseball
it's the only sport i like
it's the only sport i would watch really
i've been a yankee fan
since i was in the womb pretty much
and now it's very difficult the update
on baseball is 14 players from the miami
marlins
have just tested positive for kovid so
they canceled the opening day
and they might have to cancel the whole
mlb season not just the marlin season
but the whole mlb season
which is know i hope the players are all
fine i mean it's sad that they've got
this virus
uh in terms of what it means for the
season i don't know that it's the worst
thing to cancel this season
it's off on a pretty bad foot it's first
of all it's very truncated it's only 60
games
and also all the players are
disrespecting the american flag so i'm
kind of done with it anyway
i'm a lifelong yankee fan and
they are dead to me now they are dead to
me because
at that nats opening game that uh last
week
the yankees knelt for the national
anthem now
some people say that's not fair because
actually the yankees knelt before the
national anthem
they didn't kneel during the night it
was before so that's cool right that's
good we're all good right
no in fact kneeling before
the national anthem almost made it worse
because not only was it traitorous not
only was it unpatriotic
but it was also disingenuous it was just
them trying to thread that needle of
like hey guys
i'm doing it so everybody on the woke
left should like me but i'm not doing it
like totally in the it's like a few
seconds away so you guys like me too
right we're good we're all good right
i don't have to pick a side i yeah i
hate america and i love america hey it's
cool right we're cool
we're all good play ball no
there's no middle ground here there's no
meet in the middle between i hate
america and i want to burn it down and i
want to set the flag on fire
and i support my country there's no
middle ground there's not like yeah i
sort of hate it
yeah i'm going to burn half the american
flag i don't think so
i don't think so what if they kneel
before the national anthem what is the
message
first of all let's start if they kneel
during the national anthem what's the
message they used to tell us it was
about police brutality i think we now
know that was a complete lie
right after you know after
colin kaepernick initially said it's
about the you know he's kneeling at the
american flag but it's not about the
american flag
then he went after the betsy ross flag
which is the american revolution flag
which doesn't seem to have any
connection to police brutality
now they are burning down the entire
country and tearing down george
washington i think it's
i think it's pretty clear at this point
it's not about police brutality it's
about
a an in a central deep-seated
hatred of the united states
that's what kneeling at the national
anthem the star spangled banner symbol
of the whole country stands for
so what does kneeling before it stand
for
presumably it's part of the same protest
right
and even if the protest is taken on its
own terms you're kneeling and saying
yeah this is a
hopelessly racist country and there's a
scourge of cops or law enforcement
who by the way are a symbol for the law
itself or
are slaughtering innocent black men
willy-nilly coast-to-coast yeah
terrible country yeah yeah man these
guys are awful
and then you stand up for the anthem
what is how are you you've just
contradicted yourself
because you've you've granted the whole
protest of the anthem you've granted the
premise
but then you stand up for it anyway
because you're spineless well i don't
want to see a bunch of spineless people
throw a ball around that's not very very
exciting usually people without spines
aren't good at throwing baseballs anyway
it's disgusting it's disgusting stuff
and you know people say
sports should not be political uh you
know i i i
for what that's worth i agree with that
i you know i i don't watch sports
to get a jolt of politics but in a
deeper sense
sports must be political sports have
always been political
in this very basic way they've always
been patriotic
going back again to ancient greece
sports have always been
patriotic and
now they're the opposite of patriotic
now they're traitorous
now they're not even they're not they're
not neutral
they are attacking the symbol
of our country
they need they should be more political
in the sense that we need to get them
back to that base level i don't want to
hear about health care policy during a
baseball game
i don't want to hear about tax policy i
want to hear about any of that nonsense
but i want my sports teams to celebrate
my country if they're not doing that
i'll find another sport
isn't there there's some new football
league of like ladies do you see that i
think it was some
they're just they're always starting up
some new kind of fake football league
but i'll go to that i don't even
i don't like football and i don't watch
women's sports but i'll watch that
i'll watch i will be much more likely to
watch a sport
that doesn't openly disrespect our
country and that's exactly what major
league baseball did
and i'm sorry to say even the new york
yankees and i
never would have expected that they
would do it new york yankees
they're such rule followers they're such
sticklers they that when steinbrenner
was still alive
he wouldn't let players have a beard
jason giambi came over to the yankees
they made him shave his beard
they were like good clean cut
all-american boys and now
and now what you know and there's still
that old generation of yankees mariano
rivera went over to the white house the
other day threw the ball around with
president trump there's that those are
great memories
but that's not what we're dealing with
now it's too bad they are
they are dead to me i'm sorry to say but
they could always change it around they
could always turn it around
if they wanted to and i hope they do i
hope they listen to this show and i hope
they do turn it around
i was reminded of this when president
trump sat down with
another guy well known for sports dave
portnoy
ceo of barstool sports had a sit-down
interview with president trump
at the white house and he asked he
actually was a pretty good interview
people were kind of joking what's the
barstool sports guy doing interviewing
trump he gave a great interview
he asked him specifically about the
tweets a question i think a lot of us
have wondered he said hey
man to man here do you ever send out a
tweet and then
regret that you sent out the tweet do
you ever wish you hadn't
done that trump's answer very telling
do you ever tweet out and be like wake
up oh man i wish i didn't send that one
out often too often
yeah you know it used to be in the old
days before this you'd write a letter
and you'd say this letter's really bad
you put it on your desk and then you go
back tomorrow and you say oh i'm glad i
didn't send it right
but we don't do that with twitter right
we
put it out instantaneously we feel great
and then you start getting phone calls
did you really say this i say what's
wrong with that
and you find a lot of things you know
what i find it's not the tweets it's the
retweets that get you in trouble
you've been caught with retweeting
people like oh you just retweeted this
crazy person until you don't even look
you just press the retweet there's fire
from the hip
you see something that looks good and
you don't investigate it and you don't
look at what's on the helmet exactly
right which is in miniature and you
don't blow it up and sometimes it's
but i i have found almost almost always
it's the retweets that get you in
trouble a lot of wisdom
in that whole answer it's not the tweets
it's the retweets that get you in
trouble in this culture it's
association there's guilt by association
which the left used to pretend they
didn't
like remember mccarthyism they didn't
they oh mccarthyism so terrible because
it's guilt by association
well now of course they inflict guilt on
us by association on everybody
if you've ever been seen with anybody
who's ever been seen with anybody who's
ever been seen
with someone wearing a maga hat you
could lose your job
and that that has permeated the culture
too
it causes in a way to become more
relentlessly partisan
it causes you to lose perspective even
in a way that would help your own party
when you become so locked in that way
and then
and then the other thing that trump
reminds us of is
you can just undo the tweet you just
delete the tweet you can
change course and we don't really care
about one tweet or that tweet
but we're seeing president trump change
course right now
we're seeing him change course on his
campaign
go from weak attacks and what seemed to
be a weak strategy
to stronger attacks would seem to be a
stronger strategy you can do that i mean
we've got what a little 100 days to the
election something like that
anything can change anything can change
in politics anything can change
in this life you can turn it around on a
dime major league baseball could turn it
around on a dime frankly even these
cities under siege
could turn it around on a dime and and
right before this 2020 election
the president could turn it around too
you've just got to be willing to do it
the thing that prevents you from doing
that is pride because
in this culture everything's public
everything's online private people are
giving public apologies right
private people are defending their
actions and in the public because we all
have social media
and you dig in you you make something
you've said or done
a matter of your own identity and you
can't divorce it but you can you can
change your mind you can turn it around
we can switch up our messaging we can
win new voters the left is losing the
middle we can take the middle
we can seize the means of production we
can win
it takes a little bit of humility and a
little bit of courage both of those are
in short supply these days
but if we can get them we've got a good
path in november that's our show i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy bourie
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. hey
everybody it's andrew clavin host of the
andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton